[Music]
we're so happy to have you here tonight
this is the the last talk at the
interval for 2018 and it's a really
special one we are so happy to welcome
Kim Stanley Robinson back for his third
talk here and when when he gave his
first talk two years ago and Stewart
brand our co-founder president was
interviewing him and and and this is a
video you can go back and watch he's
talking about the political ideas in his
novel New York 21:40 he he talks a bit
about his literary DNA and his
intellectual DNA and he talks about the
teachers he had and that was the first
time that I had heard like a lot of us
knew that Ursula K Le Guin was one of
his teachers along with Fredric Jameson
Gary Snyder and a number of other
amazing folks so as Ursula Le Guin one
of our great writers passed away at the
beginning of this year as we reach the
end of this year and we're and Stan and
I were talking about what he might want
to talk about this time despite the fact
he has a new novel and a wonderful new
novel out himself he got really excited
when we talked about the idea of of
looking to talk about his relationship
with Ursula her importance to society
and to literature and well everything
he's going to tell you about here in a
second so I just just it's going to be a
wonderful night and this is the you know
this is the debut Stan put this together
just
for tonight and please reflect on that
as you give them a big round of applause
we're so happy to have Kim Stanley
Robinson back Stan
well first I want to thank Michaels so
much for bringing up the idea of getting
to talk about Ursula Gwyn is a huge
pleasure for me so it's good to see
everybody and it is lovely to be able to
give this particular talk because I it's
I've never done it before and it said
it's a it means a lot to me so thank you
and thank you Stuart and Cameron and
everybody else so I'm gonna talk for 45
minutes and I'm gonna split it into
chapters here I'm going to talk about
the Lwin as a a figure in American
literature and I'm gonna talk about my
first encounter with Lagoon and then
about her as a writer and then my last
encounter with Lagoon and then a kind of
a wrap-up so to start with you got to go
back to the 1950s and so she was born in
27 I think it was there 29 she's born in
29 and in the 50s she was a young
married woman and she was beginning to
have children and she was came from a
family academic family and
anthropologists the famous Cobre alfred
and theodore berkeley girl but merida of
guy lagoon from portland and his up in
portland oregon she was writing she was
writing fiction and for 10 years it
didn't sell but what you have to
understand is that the 1950s for science
fiction was a period of being part of
the modernist split between high art the
good stuff and popular art the bad stuff
it was a severe split you either did one
or the other and science fiction coming
out of the pulps was the other it was my
comic books or any a pornography any
other trashy thing that that people who
weren't educated did but educated people
didn't read it but the people writing it
were engineers and by the 50s they were
really accomplished writers they were
smart they were mostly men but not all
men maybe 80% of them were men
and they were writing really some of the
smartest stuff done in the 1950s to know
public acclaim whatsoever not from the
literary culture and no money whatsoever
being paid sometimes less than a penny a
word so I call this the broken
generation people like Alfred Bester or
bud dress or Damon Knight or Frederik
Pohl Edgar Pangborn Walter Miller you
look at their life their careers as
artists and they're broken
there's years where they were
dysfunctional or not writing or they
couldn't write or they couldn't sell
they did other things they took other
jobs they they became alcoholics that
the the generation is littered with
broken careers
it was hard and sensitive people some of
them were tough and they said it's just
the way it is I happen to be interested
in a strange art form sensitive Souls
like philip k dick were permanently
psychologically damaged by being looked
down on like this and talked about the
years when he had to eat dog food and so
on and so forth
so Lwin wrote for ten years short
stories and novels and couldn't publish
a thing people would write back
rejection letters and I you know it
marked someone when their website still
includes facts reproductions of
rejection letters from the 1950s you
write well but this is so obscure this
is so weird this is so distant we don't
get it and she's much like Jean wolf in
this case and that's who my match in
many ways including their greatness and
both of them were writing through the
1950s with no sales at all and one-time
junk loot and I had Jean wolf on stage
and were interviewing him like a
nutcracker with a Brazil nut you know he
was not gonna crack but we were pressing
him really hard I said to him Jeanne ten
years of writing stories sending him out
and getting rejected every time what
that do to you he said it made me mean I
said he said and then I said what do you
mean well I'm like a dog on a chain you
if you're outside the length of the
chain you're okay you get inside the
link that chain you're gonna get bit
well this was Gene Wolfe but the thing
is Ursula and Jane had a lot in common
and I think that those ten years of
rejection marked her
and why wouldn't it ten years is a long
time and they weren't her 20s they were
her 30s maybe they're her 20s they were
a little of both it took a long time and
finally she began to sell and it was to
Seeley Goldsmith editor of Fanta
fantastic magazine and she sold
assembly's necklace a short little
fantasy short story and then she had
been writing these kind of stories all
along but somehow Ursula hadn't got it
that there was a world there waiting for
her an audience there so she began to
publish in the science fiction magazines
and she began to publish at ace books
these little novels the first Hamish
novels and Terry car he told me once
that he when he got these Hamish novels
he was published in the days he got the
ACE specials and she sent in a new
manuscript and it was the left hand of
darkness he said I finished that book
and I walked down Mahan Street and I was
walking 3 feet off the ground so she had
found a place and in those first books
she resembled a crowd of people Jack
Vance
Edgar Pangborn the planetary romance and
everybody understood her to that she fit
right in and she had a community at that
thing of fellow writers and of readers
and then she began to stick out because
left and a darkness lathe of heaven
Wizard of Earthsea
and the dispossessed all came in about a
five-year period and at that point and
nine lives this short story that is one
of the best short stories ever well at
that point everybody realized in the
community she doesn't just fit in she's
a star she's one of the leaders of the
new wave it wasn't just her there was
Delaney Zelazny Tom dish and they were
translating them and mr. got Sookie
Brothers the new way was hot and but she
was as as hot as any of them she was a
one of the most prominent of the new
wave in that period of time and then it
the Kroeber connection helped if she
wasn't a good writer it wouldn't have
mattered a damn but since she was a good
writer people could also say well she
comes from this incredible American
tradition of wonderful
anthropologists is an American
intellectual aristocracy you might say
that helped the name Lagoon exotic and
French that helped it was all be an
academia was getting interested in
science fiction too and that helps
because they said well who should we
read and quickly because academics want
to only write about writers that
everybody else has already read so that
they can get their articles published so
the process of canonization is
incredibly rapid so who did you write
about you wrote about lagoon or philip k
dick 50% maybe 80% of the first academic
articles about science fiction about
Ursula and about philip k dick because
that they knew that they could write
articles and other people would at least
have known who they were talking about
so she began to bust out a little bit
the academic attention the big the great
books the sense that she was an
aristocrat and she was a kind of a
spokesperson and she was feisty and
sharp funny and charismatic and began to
get published in The New Yorker began to
be treated as if she was a real writer
and at that point also modernism myself
was falling apart post-modernism is
different than modernism and
post-modernism you can be the great
comic book artist art Spiegel you know
and post-modernism is a different
culture than the old high-low split
right now no matter what you do a
graphic novel or painting with poster
paint on that wall over there or
Abramovich doing the incredible things
that she does with her body on stage
he'd do anything and it could be great
art there is no a value system of a good
art versus a better and Ursula was
writing that wave and also making that
happen
so in she became kind of what you would
say the entry drug to science fiction
say you had a friend oh I'm interested
in science fiction you know you're a
geek you're a science fiction right or
what should I read and read the left
hand of darkness if you don't get that
you won't get you know you're not you're
not suited for this genre
and so that that was true for so many
people that Ursula was the one that you
could understand
she was accessible she was clear she was
into New Yorker
she was the point man there was still
condescending people the more
post-modernism means that all art firms
are equal the more the people who were
committed to high modernism to the idea
that there and a priest perhaps of a
religion where there's really good or
there's literary fiction and then there
was popular fiction the more your hold
to that you're on an island the tide is
rising the island is getting smaller you
get more vehement you don't say I'm
gonna swim off with the rest of these
people in the swamp you get more
vehement she took a lot of that and she
gave it right back well yes that's what
you're gonna say then you're wrong and
this is why I and she was tough and
convincing and again very charismatic so
right about in the middle of that was
when I first met it all right 1977
I had gone to UCSD I'd gone off to
Boston to go to graduate school and
truthfully i wimped out in boston
because it was so cold it was the first
winner of my life I was a kid from
Southern California and Boston dirty
snow on the streets cold my feet right
on the radiator steam radiator people
are indoors all the time I mean how can
you abide that so I bailed my first
winter I went back to UCSD and when I
got back to UCSD I thought Stan that was
stupid um you know UCSD wasn't the same
I wasn't the same you can't go home
again and it's all true and I was in San
Diego thinking I had ruined my life and
you know I was in my 20s I actually
thought I'd ruined my whole life and I I
was in graduate school I told everybody
there call me Kim I was Kim Robinson Kim
Robins and you know how are you I'm Kim
it was like part of my depression it was
part of my schizophrenia about being in
graduate school compared to being a real
writer because I still at that point
being trained as a modernist thought
that there were pale faces and ready
in American literature didn't realize
that was totally a construct and
nonsense to begin with but I was a red
Indian so what was I doing in graduate
school well Kim was in graduate school
so then suddenly there's a notice in my
mailbox at UCSD we're gonna Ursula
Gran's gonna come teach for a month
sprinkler this was 1977 I had read the
dispossessed I was completely blown away
by these books she's coming to UCSD I
thought maybe I haven't ruined my life
after says she came for a month
she taught two classes in fact when she
arrived she she only came for a month
because she didn't want to be away from
her husband ten weeks so they made a
special arrangement for her and my
friend Lowry pay talked for the first
six weeks and then she came and taught
for the last four and he just shifted
over to like a teaching assistant
wonderful guy Lowry and she she said oh
who are you I said I'm Stan Rob's and
pay looks at me yes wait I thought you
were Kim Rob so I said well I'm Kim and
graduate school and you know I'm Stan
when I'm down at the beach he's like
whoa and she looked at Ursula Ursula
looks at him and he's schizophrenic I
mean I have no idea and she said you
know actually in the science fiction
community Larry and this guy counts as
really normal so she was already hip to
science fiction strangeness and so in
that month she talked to classes and she
had office hours three three hours a
week and I want to read you the book
list because I think this and self is
interesting one classes in science
fiction one was a writing workshop and I
took both why wouldn't you
so she assigned these novels hard to be
a god by this Tchaikovsky Brothers
Martian time slipped by philip k dick
camp concentration by thomas dish the
invincible by Stanislaw LEM
v Hedda Cerberus by Gene Wolfe the dream
master by Roger Zelazny
the Exile waiting by Vonda MacIntyre and
at and strange at bat and the trees by
Michael Bishop and the MacIntyre and
Bishop r2 Lagoon pastiches of the late
70s so they're kind of like works that
were in the mode of LeGrande and I
not even sure she recognized that but I
did and she also had just discovered
Italo Calvino so Baron in the trees and
the non-existent knight in the cloven
vikon when she published together she
wanted to talk about those those were
new discoveries for her so these were
this is literary science fiction she's
not just saying in these books first of
all it's not her competitive colleagues
competitors slash in the new wave it's
sort of some of them are like Zelazny
but a lot of them are she's saying
science fiction is so big that people
like Calvino like this to God sees like
the lamb it's not just that it's as good
as the ordinary literary fiction of the
late 70s it's better 1977 if you could
collect a collection of books like that
out of the literature out of what we
call mainstream literature of the
previous 10 years you could not do it I
swear it's an amazing list and she was
happy to discuss it and then she also
had her the Writing Workshop and she
also had her office hours so I would
walk by and kind of look over in her
office it's on them the Muir campus I
think at UC San Diego and she'd just
been assigned one of the offices along
the rest I'd walk along Ursula Gwen's
holding office hours there's nobody
there
this is like a crime against nature is
like some cosmic waste of time so I
would drop in and so she knew what she
had she had a ambitious young science
fiction writer who has just barely begun
and didn't haven't written anything much
worth of anything I had been to client
and I knew science fiction backward and
forward but she read everything that I'd
written that was only a half dozen
stories and she read this big long
novella of mine that later became the
third part of ice henge but at that
point it was just a mess it was actually
three all three parts of ice and just
whooshed together and not unpacked yet
by Damon Knight as which he did later so
she reads at all losers office in her as
we talked we chatted we became friendly
and she was what do you think of this
novella or salon she goes well I really
like this type of that you make where
every time you type the word laughs
being left-handed and typing fast I
always type the a before the L and this
is before computers of course it's on a
typewriter
I was Allah she says I love this word of
love don't you love this word of love
and I'm looking I've been lady this is
my magnum opus and here so really what
she was saying was you know keep writing
she would always say that she cried and
so there was a group of students there
that she called the Barstow five and the
burst of five were as bad as working
they were out of the desert okay and
they were what we would now call food
insecure they were spending more money
than they had to go to college and their
writing was great and she stayed in
contact with him for a long time
and I said to where this these stories
are so good
them why are we doing science fiction
when these realist stories about
hardscrabble desert life are so good
already
well you need to you need to work on
that maybe figure that out and so I
wrote ridge-running a story about
backpacking and about him
a young man brain-damaged in the High
Sierra you know as a science fiction
story cuz they fixed his brain by
chemical means by his app but it was
also obviously a realist story about a
young person who had discovered the
Sears she goes oh yes now that's a
pretty damn good story that's what she
should do more of she told me and that
really was in it probably the most
important lesson that I got from her out
of my science fiction classes with her
and then it was in 77
we went down as a class to see this new
movie Star Wars together so I saw Star
Wars with Ursula K Le Guin sitting on my
immediate left and we laughed our heads
off we loved that movie and here's the
thing in 77 this was just a silly parody
of space opera it fitted in with Buck
Rogers in the 25th century or Kentucky
Fried movie in the mid 70s there was a
genre of ridiculous Donner parodies and
this one fit in perfectly and we laughed
our heads up so later when she was more
ompletely correct about Star Wars I
think I I can remember
her heartily laughing throughout the
entirety of the first Star Wars movie
and the other thing I remember
distinctly from that time is there was
an end-of-the-year class party and so it
was when one of the students apartments
it was too crowded
and and she was sitting on the floor
next to an armchair with one of the
Barstow five gals in the armchair and a
nurse was just simply sitting on the
floor talking to people so at that point
I was 25 she was 47 I thought of her as
immensely old when I was because that's
what 25 year olds thing but she was only
47 at the time and it was um it was a
wonderful month I'll put it that way and
afterwards it was simply a
correspondence between us we didn't stay
particularly close letters would pass
back and forth they were short letters
less than a page always from her and
only when there was a reason to be in
communication and there really wasn't
many reasons to be in communication so
the letters that I got from her I saved
them and I they were special enough cuz
they always would contain a joke every
Ursula letter or email would be I'm kind
of goofy and jokey she like puns she
liked to make wordplay in various kinds
of a joke so I saved him and I put him
in a special place
it was place so special I can't find him
anymore
it's that special place I'm pretty sure
they still exist somewhere in my house
so I'm gonna tear my house down right
down to the studs at some point and I'm
gonna find those damn letters but right
now I don't know where they are so let
me talk about her as a writer a little
bit now and this is I find peculiar all
of her novels are really good some are
great all are interesting and there's a
lot of them but right from rock anons
world to the last novel lavinia
particularly fine when they're all
really good and interesting the novellas
are very often superb and there's a lot
of them and there's a big book at the
back of theirs have collected novellas
that's got to be one of the best books
ever
her short stories are often great 9lives
when the best short stories ever and she
would use short stories to experiment
she would play around and she would try
goofy things or she would write the
story backwards so she would do
surrealism realism metaphysics
metafiction and mainly she used short
stories to experiment and a lot of it's
really good and her nonfiction is really
smart there's about five books of essays
about science fiction and she's
clarifying for people what is this thing
going on why did she end up in science
fiction and fantasy and she does a
really good job of it and basically her
nonfiction is a defence of doing more
than the domestic realism of the 1950s
American academic / New York
establishment her what she's saying is
literature was always bigger than that
literature is just part of story story
is Paleolithic probably pre-human and in
any case it's a realm that has always
been a form of fantasy and literary
realism of the domestic type that was
high modernism's goal in the 30s 40s and
in the academies in the 50s it's just a
tiny tiny slice of the pie chart of the
greater picture of story and that's
really what her nonfiction says in quite
a bit of detail and her poetry I well
let me talk about what I think she one
of her strongest qualities as a writer
is what I call the clean line what I
mean by that is comes out of surfing
movies we would watch surfing movies in
the 70s whole crowds of us in Southern
California we'd watch people surf but
it'd be like 500 surfing rides in a row
and that would make the movie crazy but
um the there were surfers up there that
on the wave and the waves are always
different you're adapting yourself to
the wave as it comes and you're writing
it people were too baroque and elaborate
they did too many switchbacks they did
too many spinners they'd come off the
wave and then come back down the
audience would laugh or jeer you know
surfers know oh you're an idiot you know
they hated that kind
so then there would be the surfers kind
of like Gerry Lopez that would do a
clean line
it was perfectly fitted to what the wave
gave them oh that's so beautiful
the clean line is an appropriate farm
fitting function or sentences that flow
that get to the point that stay focused
the whole way through Ursula has a
really clean line and everything that
she ever wrote and I admire this because
one of the things that takes his focus
on what is your story really about so if
you're writing a novel there's two years
that are passing you're reading about it
doing research for it you learn lots of
stories and what happens to me is
anything well all these stories are so
great I have to put them all in and I go
into a fit an obsessive fit I'm thinking
that's so interesting I can't possibly
not include it and so is this and so is
that
and so my novel is kind of like they
began to bulge as I want to tell every
great story that I ever occurs to me
during the two years of writing the
novel it's you know it's something I
can't control
Ursula she would know what the story
needed to tell you in order to make the
maximum effect for however long it was
so who novels aren't very long and
they're in in proportion to how long
they are because she made them as long
as they needed to be let me I want to
read a sentence to you yeah this is a
little section on it just to give you a
sense of it it is always the year one
here only the dating of every past and
future year changes each New Year's Day
as one counts backwards or forwards from
the unitary now so it was spring of the
year one and Erin rang capital city of
car Hyde and I was in peril of my life
and did not know it I was in a parade
I walked just behind the Gaza wars and
just before the king it was raining rain
clouds over dark towers rain falling in
deep streets a dark storm beaten city of
stone through which one vein of gold
wine slowly it's that image you just see
it and I think her sentences this comes
from the very first pages of the left
hand of darkness it struck me at the
time and I've never forgotten it I could
find it very quickly when I was putting
this talk together her sentences are
like that line of gold they run through
the thing and they're a kind of living
wire of thought that you can follow when
you read it and that I think is really
part of her talent as a writer and then
of course the content she's strange but
she's not too strange to understand and
she again keeps it a focus on the main
point so most of her stories have one
strange thing and everything else is
more familiar to you so you can accept
it she's also that's what makes her
available to so many readers almost any
reader who enjoys any kind of fiction
can actually understand the gwyn you
don't have to be a specialist in science
fiction or know the history of science
fiction she can indeed be her entry jug
for that reason and she there's also a
playfulness to her a playfulness and a
sense of humor even in her and heaviest
stories and maybe it's not true say of
Tejano but for every one of the river
novels no matter how much she is
basically a serious writer there's a
playfulness in the prose and in them and
in the talk between the characters which
is and I wanted this picture up here to
kind of convey that that's a quality in
her writing right there so there's
something that you can only put together
as a kind of a gestalt that has to do
with um intelligence and creativity a
kind of a vision a warmth the warmth is
important and I'm going to come back to
that and it adds up to something that we
often call wisdom or greatness I'd like
I prefer the word greatness because who
knows what wisdom is in this world but
the the great artists have some quality
that actually as you might be able to
tell from what I'm saying now you can't
quite put your finger on it
but you know it's there when you've read
enough of that writer it doesn't mean
that they are the finest stylists or the
most political in fact that is often the
surfer that's doing too many turns it's
more has to do with the content of what
she's saying and it doesn't have to do
with being deadly serious you don't have
to be and I want to even name the
writers who try to convince you that
they're important by their deadly
seriousness that isn't what she would do
so now I want to move on to my last
encounter with her which was I'm
perfectly pleasant and beautiful so
nothing sad about it it was an accident
that it was the last time that I saw him
but because I expected to again and it
happened up in Oregon what happened is I
had begun going on book tours and when I
went through Portland
I would I would contact Molly gloss and
Molly gloss was another student of the
Guin's that Lwin met in a writing class
that she ran in Portland she ran into
Molly lip gloss Molly gloss ran into her
the Molly is about 75 now they were very
close they became very close friends and
Molly is a wonderful writer and
wonderful person and and I admit her
through some other science fictional
context and so I she became the mediator
or the one saying well if you're having
a lunch of me have lunch with Ursula to
write on I'm ready for that so we began
to get together and one time when I got
together with her solo and this must
have been and I reckon now I must have
been about 2007 or 2008 she mentioned
that her older brother Karl had just
turned 80 and that he had gotten a fish
shrift from his friends in his
university Karl Kroeber was an academic
who wrote mostly about romantic poetry
great book on byron and romantics
somewhere maybe in Virginia Virginia
Tech or Virginia State and he said my
Ursula's gone man my brother or all his
friends put together this fishery after
him everybody is what a what a cool
thing that was I could see on her face
that she thought it was indeed a really
cool thing
so I bring this yeah I did 80
exclamation point memories and
reflections on Ursula K Le Guin what can
you give a writer who has everything
this is the back cover of this book in
2009 Ursula K Le Guin turned 80 for
decades she has shared with all the
readers that gifted were writing in
return Kim Stanley Robinson wanted to
give her a very special prison this is
not true a fresh rift privately
commissioned some Cecily bound anthology
of pieces written in her honor Karen joy
Fowler and Debbie not gun
those are the ones who did it gathered
personal essays poems stories and
academic girls for readers and writers
who loved lagoon's work the presentation
and copy of this book was given to her
and then it got published by Aqueduct
press later on well this is just Karen
and Debbie being nice because I think I
mentioned it too can't fail her Oh
Ursula would sure loved her brother
getting a fish shrift and then Karen
took it from there but they were just
Karen was like giving me credit for the
idea well I think this actually upped my
credit with Ursula as well so that was a
very nice thing because these lunches
were quite fabulous through the late
nineties me going up to Portland you
know a book signing is a book sunny but
when you have lunch with Ursula and
Molly beforehand it becomes much more of
a special event so a couple years later
out of the blue an email this is by
taught by now we're in an email land
from lagoon hey Stan as I think I told
you I was planning to I took the your
rear years of rice and salt to read on a
fairly stressful trip to New York and
Ottawa
it was a most wonderful traveling
companion the book I always knew you'd
write you indicated that was maybe the
book of your heart I should think it
would be it is so full of life blood
rich and warm the devices are elegant
and fascinating and the people remain
intensely human and faithful to their
knowledge I love the ending what a grand
book thank you dear Stan and so that's a
great email right
I'm thinking wow it blew my mind it
actually serves as my bookmark in my
copy of the years of rice and salt is a
permanent thing and also she always
called me a Kim Stan she would in it
this was her name for me because of my
original schizophrenia and our original
relationship it was always sometimes
she'd call me stim McCann so when she
signed my copy the dispossessed - Kim /
Stan underneath that stim slash can you
know love Ursula and so and one time she
said yeah Kim Stan it's it's one of the
Stan's it's in Central Asia it's kind of
a sloppy country so kind of a you know
it's kind of a mess so when she actually
said thank you dear Stan well this is
this is a little Ursula it's not a
mistake I'm positive
so all these good things happening and
Charles Goodrich who ran a program at
Oregon State which is in Corvallis said
will you come give us a talk we have a
weekend on sustainability issues it's a
big festival everybody's going to
display their cool stuff Corvallis total
hippie town they're gonna love it and
would you come speak and I said if you
can get her slow then I'll come and you
said you know I was thinking of trying
that and I said well look tell her
I'll pick her up in Portland I'll Drive
her to Corvallis I'll Drive her back if
she wouldn't have to do anything
door-to-door service it's like lift
before lift is that it'd be me and he
goes okay I'll try it and she wrote back
to him and said yeah I'll do that so
suddenly for the first time after
meeting the 70s and this is like 2013 I
think we're doing an event together at
Oregon State and we planned it we
planned it down to a tee emails actually
a couple months let's go we worked it
out eventually we would go back and
forth ten minutes each three times each
read for an hour she didn't want to talk
at all she wanted to read only she
wanted to read her poems most of all and
I said fine and it was something that
I've been doing with friends if we
actually have a gig on stage where you
read each other's work
in a small section because this is such
a fun thing to do the audience's know
it's unusual it's it's it's only gonna
happen at one time and so she agreed to
that too
so I read three or four of her poems we
decided that we wouldn't give ten
minutes to each other but only five
minutes to each other so that we had
most of the time reading her own stuff
and and she read from my book Shaymin
which had just been published a little
bit before and she said oh god finally
are done with these emore I'm so tired
of your immortal characters so suddenly
I it wasn't like she ever hid this from
you because as an aside I will say if
there's ever anything that Ursula didn't
like that you were doing it was like you
were immediately slapped like a mosquito
it's like she was very dialectical and
she took no [ __ ] so um if she was
annoyed or irritated like I once I made
a joke about Virginia well don't you
joke about one time I said you know your
books erodes which is a very beautiful
story collection about a coastal town in
Oregon I said you know there's not a
single nice man a male character in that
entire book she goes well don't say that
fifteen years later I was reading an
interview with her and she says Stan
Robinson doesn't think there's any good
men care business to dress but he forgot
about the mailman
I definitely forgot the meal so you
couldn't mess with her and what I
realized is that she really did love
Shaymin because she yourself had this
love for Native Americans for primitive
what we her father would call primitive
cultures for for the first peoples as we
would call them now she loved that stuff
with all her heart and so she liked my
novel Shaymin and she read from it and
she read a scene that I never would have
read to any audience ever I wouldn't
have had the courage where Thorin is
dying he's talking to Lou and he's
trying to pass along the oral knowledge
that loses that you lose when people die
in an oral culture where there is no
writing he's trying to pass it along in
a last series of talks she read that
aloud and this the hair was standing up
off the back of my neck it was probably
the most intensely something between
appalled and amazed and happy that I've
ever felt on stage it was scary stuff
but she didn't care it was one of those
flat affective readings that she was so
good at it was a quite astonishing
moment for me and so we finished you can
see this on YouTube
we're afterwards we stood we held hands
we bowed like a theater troupe of two we
were totally geeked out there were eight
hundred Oregonians and plaid with beards
and wool that had been raining all day
it was her audience absolutely and 800
Oregonians giving a sustaining ovation
at the end of a reading which you don't
usually get and I looked at her and I
thought you know weird this is exactly
what we became writers not to be doing
is up on stage like this geeking out you
can see it actually on the YouTube or
both of us like okay get us out of here
get us to the bar we drank some scotches
that night she said we did good and the
next day was actually the best part we
drove back home to Portland and she was
a navigator she said don't take the
freeway that's so boring oh I'll get us
back home we had no map I'm thinking
okay whatever and she pretty much knew
the way his back roads she was maybe
improvising and knew that all the ways
would eventually get you back to
Portland and during that day we had a
talk that drive back home that was
probably the best talk I ever had with
her and we talked about many things one
part of it was about Virginia Woolf
where we liked her sentence structures
like there's a thing that wolf does and
I brought it up first where whether
people can be trusted with other
people's reputations even when you're
not there and everything's on the line I
doubt or and then she laughed and she
said yeah yeah there's another thing
just like that that I like the fate of
the British Empire rests on the sturdy
shoulders of 12 men scattered across the
globe but no this is full and so we had
a good time in it at some point she said
well Stan why I mean you talk about
climbing all the time you do on these
talks I can't talk I only do fiction and
poetry and I'm thinking yeah and five
books of nonfiction but I didn't mention
that and she said why don't you publish
nonfiction it's not good enough it's you
know it's it's it's just not good enough
in she she said that sounds like vanity
she said don't be vain vanity is always
silly I said well you know it's not
vanity it's like um it's like I can't
find the narrator when I'm doing
nonfiction she says make him do it
[Applause]
but Kim's just a student that gets AIDS
you know he's not he's no good she goes
well make Stan do it well it still
doesn't know what he thinks and this is
when I began to tell her that the reason
I'm a novelist is that whatever people
talk to me I get said accidentally
hypnotized by them and they seem totally
convincing to me I believe them and I'm
thinking yeah that's right boy this
person I'm very persuadable and labile a
hyper suggestible I get accidentally
hypnotized by people all the time I'm
explaining this to her and she's going
well whatever um
just pretend it's only 5,000 words long
so pretend that you're thinking I said
okay maybe I will
and actually I never have I still feel
like there's a problem with my
nonfiction that has not been solved but
it was that was when I realized how much
I loved her that even that's when you
realize you love that you love someone
when they are admonishing you or even
scolding you you're thinking oh this is
so great this person really understands
me so it doesn't matter what they say to
you at that point because you're engaged
with them so um that was pretty much it
and I will say that when I got back to
her house and dropped her off I said can
you give me a rock and she said
definitely
and so she understood cuz actually on
her mantelpiece was a selection of rocks
that she loved and she knew that I was
going to take a rock from her place and
I put him in my patio where I right
underneath me now in the middle is Lwin
but also right next to her
a rock from Virginia Woolf place also
robinson jeffers cecilia Holland
Shackleton's Beach in South Georgia
cherried Garrard's little rock Hut and
Cape Crozier Kenneth Rexroth place up at
Devil's Gulch and a big old chunk of
gold rush type rock from Gary Snyder's
place gary warned me he said this
probably isn't from this land I think
this is in fuel from somewhere else but
you can have it
and Ursula was the same she understood
she said here I'll give you some advice
if you ever forget where a rock is from
throw it into the garden immediately
because you will never remember again
where it came from and you don't want to
mess yourself up by having rocks I can
identify from where they're from
so she actually took me out to the
garden she said I think this is from her
place in Napa
it was serpentine a big old like a cube
like a maybe the size of the twice the
size of a golf ball I almost brought it
to show you but when I suggested this to
my wife last night she was looking at me
like Stan it's not show until you're not
in fifth grade to not take the rock down
there so and I have to admit it's an
ordinary rock it would not be you know
that show until it might be okay so I
have that rock back from her and that
was the last time I saw her and we had
good emails since then she's quite funny
and I guess to wrap up I would want to
say that maybe there should be a book of
memories like people used to do mmm
after especially before YouTube in film
there's a great book of memories by of
Byron by people who knew him I
particularly value ones of Virginia
Woolf herself and of joy scary
and although Ursula is well represented
on screen you know on YouTube and in
films and all that nevertheless a
collection of memories of people she
influenced and impacted I think would be
a great thing because she's going to end
up remembered and read because the books
are so beautiful and then people are
gonna wonder what was she like and
actually now maybe YouTube is replace
those books but what people might say
about her would be like me and what I'm
curious about
because after all this that I told you I
wasn't by no means one of her closest
friends or associates or even younger
writers who loved her by most of those
were women you would have to go to Molly
gloss and Karen joy Fowler and Eileen
Gunn and gwennyth Jones and Vonda
McEntire and Kelly link and the list
would go on until there would be
literally scores of wasn't writers for
Homer's
was the great moment there and I once
saw her with a very young woman kind of
kneeling before her as she was signing
books I've written a novel I've written
an apple will you light a bird I was
like looking I only write blurbs for
women publishing their first novels she
goes it is my first novel and I'm a
woman as I said all right send it to me
so she supported and she knew that
science fiction had begun very much of a
male centric genre and that because of
her prominence in our field she had
changed that by example and was an
exemplary figure and those are the
people that I think need to be their
thoughts need to be collected while we
all still have them and that would be a
beautiful addition to the can and a kind
of fish riff for her 100th birthday or
whatever well we still got around maybe
we should make it her 90th birthday but
that would be a good way to remember one
of the greatest writers in in science
fiction history who changed the game
well now everybody cooled those science
fiction because Ursula showed that it
was the best way to communicate the
reality that we live in right now so
what I say for me it's been easy I mean
I came in in the 70s and I still have a
chip on my shoulder about the size of a
you know the Transamerica Tower or the
the Salesforce tower against the
mainstream world of New York and of
literary academia for the way that they
put down science fiction back in those
years but on the other hand despite the
signs of the chip on my shoulder the the
gravity is gone
Ursula took away the gravity of that
situation by force of will and by coming
at the right time with a lot of other
people and holding people's feet to the
fire and being tough when she had to and
being one of the one of the great
writers of our time so that is my Ursula
thank you
Thank You Stan all right
warm up your questions I'm gonna get a
couple in first and well that was really
thank you so much for for putting that
together that was really wonderful well
a total pleasure as you can tell let's
get a little closer to cleaning for our
for the folks at home hi the folks at
home we've yeah and want to say if
you're watching on the livestream now do
ask questions - there's a chat box below
we'd love to get some questions from
folks at home and and and folks here as
well we're gonna have somebody walking
around with a mic in a little bit keep
an eye on them get their attention and
they'll hand you the mic
let me oh there we go thank you
now we're gonna have that happen let's
go back to to the top of your of your
talk so you you dr. Robinson dr. Kim or
dr. Stan Robbins Jana you - Kim so you
you got your PhD at UCSD and that seems
like sort of an unusual I mean I don't
know maybe I'm just not aware of it but
we're we're there a lot of it seems like
a lot of folks just sort of were just
jumping into writing was that a I did
did you hold off on on publishing did
you feel like you wanted to get to a
certain level or learn certain things
before you the the PhD was a job it paid
me in those years it paid me enough that
I could write on my own and it was the
it was the path of least resistance and
as I told you I felt uncomfortable about
it I thought I should have been a
lumberjack or a deep-sea fishermen or
something or maybe just a homeless
person but I was in grad school as a job
and then I I thought it was a useless
job for being a writer where you need to
actually learn
about life instead of about instead of
about literature but over the long haul
it was obviously a really good thing to
to learn the Canon my PhD is not in
creative writing which I think is well
an MFA I guess is what they call it now
but it's in literature in English and
American literature with a little bit of
French involved there was a good
education in the Canon and I know
English and American literature in a way
that well I know it way better now than
when I got the PhD cuz it takes decades
to read all that stuff but I've remained
an English major in my whole life and I
love it dearly so maybe I was doing it
for love I mean there was nothing else I
wanted to do more I enjoyed teaching
students I taught nothing but freshman
composition because that was my
seventies political position that and
also my way of saying English
departments are like Catholic priesthood
and I'm a Protestant there should only
be writers and readers there should be
not this this level of priests in
between the two so I taught freshman
composition for eleven years and I loved
it I improved a lot of writers who were
good to begin with but they didn't know
it they had been messed up by high
school or by their own preconceptions of
what good writing was and I was like the
horse the the freshman whisperer and I
could release them from this feeling
when they were and when English language
is their original language I could
improve their writing usually say
English as a second language is a
different problem and a lot harder so
that was my thing I mean I was lucky I
had fredric jameson as my adviser for
the first half of my PhD he said yeah
write about philip k dick the greatest
living American writer he said to me and
this is like 1975 and and he was in the
English department or did you kind of go
outside he was in the French department
but he was my French teacher in fact my
my exposure to Fred Jamison was equally
beautiful there was this guy with
speaking French with a strong New Jersey
accent and he he wouldn't speak any
English to us and he was given these
these plays by Sartre and Camus the
really short plays that only have like a
hundred word vocabulary it was fabulous
so my education was good and in the end
it was probably the right thing for me
yeah did you learn anything from Ursula
that you were then applying in your
teaching while you were
still teaching her oh well she was
teaching creative writing the writing of
short stories and I was teaching
freshman called
what I would say is that she was really
good at trying to understand what the
writer wanted to do in their story and
then talk to them about how they might
do that more effectively
she was the Shiva she ran it like a
Clarion Workshop and she in fact even
workshop one of her own stories in her
group here's my story and that's another
time I got slapped down I said well
that's a very whimsical story she said I
hate that word whimsical and and yet
that story has never been published in
an Ursula could have published her
laundry list if she wanted to affirm for
about ten years and so I feel like she
might have thought again about that
story which was really goofball and I
think it's probably a great story I was
just being a jerk and I also challenged
her as to a couple of the book she had
assigned in that class as were they
appropriate or not or good enough and it
was like why was I so stupid as to do
that yeah you know here at lo now we're
all about time and I have a couple
couple questions for you as a writer
over time and reflecting on Ursula
writing for time I mean she was a
trailblazer as a writer but she had this
interesting in a way she kind of broke
through some things and and is in a
transitional moment where she she talks
about how after the first three Earthsea
book she's thinking about writing the
fourth and she was hearing criticism and
thinking about how there wasn't a kind
of full female character and and and
there's criticism about that herself
criticism about that but she couldn't
figure out how to write that and that
was something that she kind of broke
through and eventually figured out how
to write that so in a way she was you
know she was almost on the frontier and
had to had to figure out how to how to
go I wonder did you have it you have a
perspective on that yeah thank you for
that because I want to it's something I
would have added if I'd had
is it I think Ursula felt that she
hadn't come to feminism in her fiction
fast enough and that Tejano was a
corrective to the patriarchal bias of
the Earthsea trilogy no and there have
been some critics who have agreed with
that and I think she's getting a bad rap
because left hand of Darkness is 1969
and then she had to watch the incredible
fireworks of Joanna Russ and of James
Tiptree jr. who Lagoon quickly knew it
was Alice Sheldon and they were in a
close correspondence Laguna and Tiptree
were good friends as pen pals really
close actually if you read the
correspondence Laguna and Russ didn't
get on because Russ was highly critical
about an ordinary housewife in a normal
heterosexual marriage with kids and her
sled well as I said she didn't like any
kind of criticism and especially an
unfair criticism she would really take
against and so I don't think she was
fond of Russ but she knew Russ was a
really brilliant writer funny and at the
level of the line it was more than a
clean line with Russ it was a a kind of
a genius for sentence making and I think
Ursula felt like well I can be as good a
feminist as Russ and Tiptree I always
have been left-handed darkness is
foundational in that sense and I think
the Guin comes out of Simone de Beauvoir
the second sex that book appeared in
English like an atomic bomb and so it
was a question of Ursula trying to prove
something that I think she had already
proved so there was a period where I
think she was over emphasizing something
that she didn't need to over emphasize
at all and it had to do with the dynamic
with Joanna Russ that's my personal
psycho biography which I tell you the
truth I would not even have said allowed
in a room with this many people
if Ursula was still alive in fact I'm
feeling a little like let's move on
[Applause]
oh well but Ursula's not gonna see it so
on a on a similar theme though about you
know we're all individuals and we move
through time society progresses and we
progress through our lives right we all
have things from our youth we may be
embarrassed about just not all of us are
getting published and sharing that with
the world and so the you know the the
earliest stories some things that you
might have regrets or have written
differently so I'm curious to in to ask
you this question but also kind of
reflecting as she sort of looked back in
that same kind of way you know we were
talking a little bit earlier so last
maybe two years ago you put out green
earth mm-hm and green earth is looking
back at three novels you'd written as as
trilogy before and re bringing the
science up-to-date and I'm not sure what
all how you retrofitted that the keep
tell us something about that
had it been bugging you is something you
needed to do was it something that an
opportunity came up that they were gonna
republish them or what's kind of the
background around green earth and how
did you think about that and kind of
going back and either correcting or
going back to your previous work well I
mostly don't look back i I can't read my
own work without just seeing it as a
series of things I I see the things that
I didn't fix it's like looking at the
backside of a stage set or something so
I don't read my own work but I was
reading a book by Peter Matheson in a
bookstore shadow country and suddenly in
his introduction he said this used to be
three novels I think it starts out with
killing mr. Watson and I shrunk it down
because I decided that it was too long
and it would he said the middle volume
was like the belly of a dachshund I'm
thinking and I thought and I'm reading
that I'm thinking anyone the National
Book Award for shadow country that the
compressed version which is very well
deserved I thought damn I wish I could
do that with my Washington DC trilogy
and as I thought that had never occurred
to me until I read about Peter Matheson
doing it and I love Peter Matheson's
right and he's a great novelist so I
thought I wonder if I can do that and my
British editor
Johnson lovely person and editor she I
asked her first because it was her in
England and the people at Bantam in the
States
and girl my editor there and it was Jane
very dynamic she said sure you can and
then she talked and girl into it and
Anne was agreeable and so I got to do it
which is a rare thing to get to go back
and I pretty much did the same as
Mathison I did update some of the
science that had in ten years it had
become either wrong or I'd realized it
was wrong or is redundant and that
everybody already knew it so I cut this
text by about fifteen percent and
truthfully most of it was just the extra
verbiage of trying to write everything
down everything I knew who as I told you
everything I knew about Washington DC
well I'd lived there for four years so
it wasn't like Mars where I wouldn't
change a word of my Mars trilogy even
having reread it I think it's as solid
as a boulder but with my DC stuff do you
really need to know the details about
where the marble for the Washington
Monument came from no you don't need to
know that so I cut it by about 15% and
it got it down into one volume called
green earth which i think is the rescue
of that novel it's a it's as far as I
can tell which is not very far it's far
better and compressed version so I'm
very grateful to Jane Johnson and n
Grohl for letting me do that hardly ever
happens and we'll get to audience
questions one second last thing before
we open it up you do have this new your
new book red moon just came out in the
last month yeah and it's wonderful thank
you and it's it's so it's involves China
and the moon and quantum phones and and
and AI and so no sport would note we're
in a no spoiler zone but I'm curious
what are there are there are the things
you would recommend we're not when I
read it you know there are there
references to current China policies and
and things like that are there things
that you would suggest to as frames of
reference to to get into this or
just dive right in what are your
relations it would be hard
I read widely and the more I read the
less I understood when it came to China
and I luckily from my UCSD freshman
writing program at fourth college I had
a friend KY Wong who was from China I
didn't know much about him but we played
we played ping pong together and I
couldn't even return his shot we played
tennis together and he tried to play
tennis like of his ping pong and and so
he couldn't return my shots so we
started playing badminton together and
we had a lot of fun we were good buddies
but I knew very little about him and I
didn't even know what KY stood for and
so this is like the 70s and I'm it was
Kim that did all that it wasn't me so he
when I got the idea that I wanted to do
a novel where China was occupying the
moon first which I really think will
happen I tried to find him well if you
google KY Wang there are like four or
five thousand of them that come up and
and this is an embarrassing thing to
admit but I hadn't seen him for 45 years
and I was looking at picture of Chinese
man after Chinese man they're all came
by Wang I mean well that could be him it
could be him I don't know you know I'm
such an Anglo I'd you can't tell I'm an
idiot but also who knows how they people
aged bla bla bla bla bla bla I finally
found him through the UCSD Alumni
Association and the moment I saw his
photos like exactly ky I would have
known and instantly it was the same same
face and so he brought me to China he
told me read
Wong Hui China in the 20th century by
Wong he is a Chinese scholar that now
works out in New York University that's
one of the only books it's basically
history but it gives you history in a
way that allowed me to also add on the
future and he's called a new leftist
Wang and he hates that it first of all
gets him in trouble back home but it
gave me a lot of thoughts as an old
leftist I'm thinking about in China what
is a new leftist and what does it mean
and so that's about the only book I
could recommend and everything else is
interesting but doesn't not illuminating
and I might say
that about my own book yeah you'll see
when you get to the last line and if you
have a question where as right there
just she's got the mic so the sci-fi
that's being written in China right now
the Chinese science fiction so a three
body problem as a lot and you I know
you've read at least a little bit more
than that what are your thoughts is and
is that are you excited about what
you're seeing there are there other
areas where there other you've talked
before about how not every country can
write sci-fi if I'm quoting you you
correctly that sci-fi doesn't happen the
different types of things happen
sometimes in different cultures am I
saying that right I think that's right I
think science fiction is an expression
of an industrialized country and that
the reason that you get magical realism
in Latin America and the generation of
Garcia Marquez is that that's the
appropriate genre for Latin America
that's the realism of Latin America
science fiction is the realism of the
United States and of England and now
every nation as it gets industrialized
and has a vision of its own future as a
nation-state you get national variations
on science fiction and China of course
is booming right now they have a sense
of their future they have a they want to
read about China in the future
specifically so lyosha Shen and the
problem for us is I'm what gets
translated into English so lucious and
three-body problem he and I did an event
together in Beijing he's a wonderful man
very a sly low-keyed funny
self-deprecating
but obviously pretty brilliant guy he
says I'm a computer programmer from a
coal plant we closed the coal plant down
I had to do something so I started
writing science fiction so the
three-body problem is a good example I
think of what they're doing and his
short story collection called the
wandering earth which is about 20 short
stories it's an expensive trade
paperback that's even better for showing
what Chinese science fiction is doing
right now because he ran the table every
possible I think he won their Nebula
word for short story six years in a row
by trying every possible variation and
what I say to people who are
haven't read them yet is he's like
arthur c clarke and philip k dick
combined into one writer if you can wrap
your head around that if you know clark
and philip k dick if you can imagine the
two of them in one writer you get lucia
shin i also there was a young woman who
wrote folding beijing john pinkness her
first name but i forget her last name
amy was just who but folding beijing is
on the internet as a short story you can
just google it and it comes up as a free
story to read excellent on a science
fiction story of what beijing feels
right now but done completely in science
fiction terminology so yeah it's gonna
there's gonna be more of it but the
question is what gets over translated
into english and and that conversation
between the two of you is on the
internet as well it's a Bhrigu and
institute here in san francisco deep are
most of the writer do you have a set do
you feel like you've got a sense of what
is happening that it's not all getting
translated but I wonder and and and as
he's he's still within China because it
is sort of interesting like books are
writing from within China things that
may be critical of well yes but it's all
coded and it's all science fiction so
that means that it's non
representational and he's getting away
with things that I find amazing and it
reminds me of philip k dick writing
against McCarthy during the McCarthy era
but nobody first of all no one was
reading him and secondly it was science
fiction so so what even though they were
very obviously allegories for the
McCarthy situation so some of the oceans
writing I think is treads a very fine
line and I have no idea how he gets away
with some of the stories had just gotten
away with I think we've got a question
over here hi I'm a nonfiction writer so
apologies in advance
[Music]
singularity which we know sometimes use
as a shorthand for AI but I take him
initially to be talking about really the
limits of the imagination that there
will be you know a transformative event
that is so transformative that it's hard
to imagine what happens after that and
if it were true that we were approaching
an event like that we would notice by
any sort of tour shortening of the
imaginative distance and so when I look
back and I think about classic science
fiction from the 50s you know they're
imagining like traveling to the moon and
computers that can understand you when
you speak to them and so forth and we're
now 75 years into the future we have
those things and at least from a pop
culture standpoint the science fiction
that I've seen recently you know the
film her or Black Mirror is all set like
five to ten years into the future not
you know a hundred years so I'm just
curious how do you think about what it
means to write science fiction in 2018
do you think there's something to this
idea that it's becoming more challenging
to kind of project the imagination out
beyond that horizon or if you think
there's sort of a tension between our
ability to imagine future things versus
the the pace of technological change
itself
um I think it is getting harder um I
don't believe in the singularity and
what I think will what's in an allegory
for like like I don't believe in time
travel what but it's still a useful
story device what I think the
singularity is about is we've already
passed that we're in the singularity or
passed through it it happened back in
2008 with the financial crash or it
happened back in the 70s the sense that
we're out of control of history and
someone else is in control of it is what
it's an allegory for the way the zombies
are allegory for the precariat and
vampires are allegory for the 1% you can
change all of the big science fiction
tropes into metaphors or allegory gelug
Oracle symbols of things that are going
on right now and then science fiction is
always about the future
it's always had because the future is
whoa infinite or seventy five billion
years depending on your cosmology near
future science fiction has always been
about the day after tomorrow and you
have you have Gibson far future science
fiction is a form of fantasy like space
opera where almost anything can be
explained because it happens five
million years from now I've only done a
little bit of that and I've done a lot
of near future science fiction the zone
in between I find particularly
interesting where you're doing just what
you're saying might be really hard right
now future is a hundred years out 150
years out given everything that's going
on right now and how fast everything is
accelerating and how the trajectories
are sometimes a 180 degrees divergent
between utopian futures and dystopian
futures or even apocalypses how do you
write that zone well you just have to
model it and pick one strand tell one
story and not try to convince yourself
it's the only story or the true story or
the most plausible story it's just one
story so you you run these things as
thought exercises and that zone is
depleted if you'll notice if you read
science fiction on a regular basis a lot
of near-future stuff a lot of space
opera what you might call future history
that hundred years in the future zone
well I like to try that but I don't and
I'll still Reynolds everyone soon I
don't know contemporary science fiction
well enough to name very many more and
and I know I'm not the only one but I
basically don't have time to read
anybody else except for a few friends
and not many friends are doing that
future history so I don't know what's
going on do you have so Redmond has just
come out I'm sure you already are at
work on the next something is in the
works I would expect at this point in
your career do you have a list of what
you want to do are you just kind of
examining the world when you are
finishing up a project to think of what
you're gonna do next how are you how are
you how are you mapping
forward from here as far as what you're
gonna what we can look forward to you
from you yeah well I have a list and
I've checked off every box and so I'm
like what am I going to do so we could
probably round something up here tonight
yeah yeah actually my editor once said I
said I'm running out of ideas he goes
Stan I can solve that problem which I
thought very reassuring I found that
very reassuring so I I I don't know I
want to write a utopian novel I want to
write what I'm calling the good anti
pristine that's what I'm writing now and
that is what it feels like swimming
uphill and in fact I was swimming up you
somebody falls but you know it's just
sentences so that I'm going to throw all
the dice on on that one and and then
after that I want to write a nonfiction
book about the Sierra Nevada just a
backpacking book or Thoreau vien
reflection and that's already looking
pretty far out in the future and beyond
that I just think you know something
will come to me and partly because of
this thinking about lagoon I've been
thinking short novels you know as a as a
form like the sonnet to poetry a hundred
and twenty page novel and I haven't done
those less than I did at that linked was
like nineteen ninety and so that's as
much as I know about my future well
thanks for sharing it yeah got a
question right here so a lot of Earth
slowly wins world building is pretty
political like possessed yes um how did
that influence you and was that
something you ever discussed and also do
you think it explicitly colored your
approach to the marsh ecology
well thank you for that yes yes and yes
and I'm glad you brought it up because
again if I had had more time I'd talk
about it and I will now Ursula's
politics were American leftist of a
different variety than mine but we were
both the kind of American left said look
the front is borrowed and we just take
our different points of view and work
together rather than the narcissism of
small differences we're left us fight
leftists because they're the only
understand the nature of the argument so
the dispossessed is an anarchist text
and men it is a very interesting and
compelling thought experiment what would
it be like to live in an anarchist
society because really anarchism is
almost like you know it's almost
politically autistic where everybody's
free and in everybody free contract
between everybody and there are no rules
and she actually wrote me one of these
emails to thank me for my introduction
to magpie killjoys anarchist I wrote the
introduction I said anarchy can mean no
rules or no ruler in the Greek and I say
it means no ruler because you have to
have rules and even on an aris there's
rules in the anarchistic society it's
like management of the Commons the
Commons was not a space where you could
do anything it was managed and regulated
and anarchism as I understand it will be
a complete horizontal ization of power
and wealth and that's the anarchist goal
a distant horizon that everybody should
be shooting for and so she and I came at
it from our different angles I'm much
more of a Marxist Leninist and Anna
statist and so she her anarchism as she
told me came out of the daodejing and
share her translation of the daodejing
is fabulously good and you need to
cross-reference it with three or four
others to realize how amorphous and
murky that document is it's but she
comes to anarchism from the dow and and
from that strain of chinese literature
that i think comes also from her father
the anthropological strain so this is
what and also I stayed up all night to
read the dispossessed I had a little
science fiction library Club a hardback
it was like shorten light I got to what
I call the Dickinson point which is the
point where you know you have to finish
this book in that city comes from Peter
Dickinson who does it all the time but I
got to that point with her and it was
like 1:00 a.m. so I stayed up to like
4:00 a.m. to read the dispossessed and
when I was done I was thinking you can
write a utopian novel and make it work
as a novel and that blew my mind that
was 1975
and and it was a huge impact on the Mars
trilogy and everything that I've done
since probably in in terms of the
content of rather than the form the
content her influence comes to me mostly
from left-handed darkness and from the
dispossessed as a gender and politics so
she was really important and I know she
still is - all anarchists and and all
American leftists who are thinking about
it
so thank you and you know when you look
at the left-handed blend of dark lift
and of darkness it's a novel about
refugees and culture clash it's a novel
about gender and and sort of levels of
trust it's a it's a it's a novel where a
society sees a potential to progress
that's kind of offered to them and and
doesn't sure if it's gonna kind of take
the offer I mean two sides of two
societies actually on on that planet so
it's it's a pretty interesting foil for
the moment we're in now with just some
of those things yeah a left hand is a
great novel I would say it's her
masterpiece and and one of the great
novels of the 20th century and it has to
do with a couple of things the the car
hide is futile the the other Society on
the other side of the world is socialist
in a bad Soviet totalitarian way there
isn't a capitalist society there's only
these two struggling and both of them
mired in their problems so it has a lot
of interesting political thoughts I
think she was thinking that maybe the
two of them together was a portrait of
the United States in the 1960s partly
futile and partly bad socialism but no
no no function no real culture and then
the gender thing for me was that most of
the time gender isn't important for
social life sometimes it is pay
attention to that and when I when my
wife and I had our first kid then she's
a scientist working 12 hours a day six
days a week and
when my boy was 10 weeks old
which I took over and was was a
caretaker of this child mr. mom as they
put it in the great movie by Michael
Keaton I was mr. mom for years and the
left hand of darkness this idea the king
was pregnant which obviously I wasn't
but the king did a lot of bottle
feedings you know they were very
maternal in their effect and I thought
yeah man I what left hand help me was to
conceptualize the feelings that I had
the structure of feeling had changed
because of that book so I was just in
the camera had come along and I was in
in my female existence and I was really
happy I was I thought I was pretty good
at it so you know this is this is
profound what literature can do for you
and and she knew that I think she knew
she had hit it out of the park with that
book was right here Thanks I I love that
sort of future history that you talked
about and one that I would recommend
very highly was this by Brewster lugar
who was just here in his schismatics
plus gets a collection and in fact it's
a novella the story I'm referring to
it's fantastic
my question is about well I walked in
and I thought Ursula you know absolute
wind I remember reading her when I was a
adolescent basically I was trying to the
name of the book there at the table and
I said you were on the one that you know
that kind of might have an issue yeah
and I and she put me in to the fact that
her father I mean just a little bit can
you talk about that relationship and
that influence on her yeah sure because
thank you see of course is also sort of
a found a cultural cornerstone here in
California yeah the first books I ever
read yeah well it was and i think super
important you know she was hanging out
with a she in the house when she was a
girl he was a member of the household
and came by a lot
knew her she knew him and it means a lot
to her and for those who don't know do
you want to just well you she was it
everybody knows right
Yawk indian the last of his tribe he she
the last of his tribe that was the
theodoric robbers book about this man
her dad
stumbled out of northeastern California
after disease plague had killed off his
tribe he was the last one left and naked
as far as I could tell he was the last
one in his language group and so a
Kroeber said well I'm an anthropologist
and I suddenly I have a Native American
in the last of his tribe they gave him a
job as caretaker he thought that the
greatest accomplishment of Western
civilization was cigarette lighters or
maybe it was matches I think it was
actually just matches he was amazed so
Theodora wrote a she last of his tribe
Kroeber was a prominent anthropologist
and Ursula's great tribute to her dead
and I suppose her mom as well would be
always coming home and that novel by
Ursula if you look at the table of
contents of always coming home and you
look at the table of contents of her
dad's book the handbook of the
California Indians they are identical
she had to have had her dad's books
table of contents in hand when she
constructed always coming home so it's a
tribute to her parents and and it's a
it's a beautiful gesture in that regard
and so I am I right to say she's one of
the first people bringing social science
or anthropology or in there it seems
like because because left hand of
darkness is is not an action no it is it
is an anthropological a culturally
analytical kind of view I it feels like
well I would say that again those 50s
guys were the science fiction writers of
the broken generation were better than
anybody remembers unless you go back and
read him and so Chad Oliver was a
professional anthropologist and his
books are quite good and
apology he wasn't anywhere near as
prominent rather minor science fiction
writer the 50s but he was an
anthropologist I would say a Jack Vance
and his ramshackle and and a fun-loving
way was anthropological and Edgar
pangborn's the planetary adventurer was
a kind of an anthropological thing and
people loved their planetary adventures
John Brunner before stand on Zanzibar
and so Brunner was doing social science
in stand on Zanzibar that's very
important and his planetary adventures
are a little anthropological but leg
when as I said in my talk was the one
that foreground the one that leaped to
the fore the books were not just
anthropological but also beautiful
so they were stories and and you had the
sense of somebody that really knew
something that wasn't a scribbler making
it up on the fly but somebody that was
resting on a body of of academic
knowledge and also first people's
knowledge so this is like the content of
our anthropology not just the form of
anthropology so it gave her a huge
advantages and and people could feel it
know going whoa this you know we've been
a bunch of engineers and a bunch of
scribblers and an advertising guy and
new york science fiction writers the the
generation of the Golden Age in the 40s
were coming to it from their love for
the future but she was coming to it from
a completely different and maybe more
intellectually well I wouldn't want to
say that because actually you got to
look at those 50s guys and Leigh
Brackett and seal Moore the women that
were in that Club Katherine MacLean and
there's actually a good new book from
library of America the future is female
it goes from 1927 up to the big three I
call them the Guin restive tree all
these women science fiction writers were
doing great work in every year from 27
to say 72 and so Lisa yosik edited that
book and it's a really good example of
that we're forgetting that there was
just lots of good science fiction but
look when was the one that brought it up
to a level where everybody could see it
there one more question for
from reinvent here um one of the things
I love about your your science fiction
is it basically pushes out into that
middle ground you know New York
underwater and 2140 the solar system
filled out with human beings in a
realistic way in 300 years or whatever
and then how do we actually get to
another solar system you know over
generations in a starship and it's also
positive and and so what I'm interested
I think this crowd would be interested
in is why is it that we don't see more
of that middle ground science fiction
what is the difficulty about that or
what is the reason that you don't see
more of that and - why don't you see
more positive science fiction because it
seems to me one of the things
politically in this country right now
you even need it's just more of a
positive way how does this all work how
do we go forward how does it all come
together you know how do we actually
move forth as opposed as dystopian
science fiction thing that it's just so
kind of prevalent that it just is so
depressing honestly and interesting the
positive side and also that middle range
side and how do we really get that more
of that yeah
the I'll take them one at a time the
middle zone is hard and I would say that
it is also a matter of reader-response
some people like to read literature
because it's about the world they're in
right now and it's and it's made
exciting by mysteries or by romance or
by intrigues of one kind or another or
by fine writing realism so that's about
now and then there's a crowd that likes
to read about space operas starships
zooming about in the galaxy the galaxy
treated as a space that we can zoom
around in and the people tend to like
one or the other or if they like one a
lot they don't like the other but this
is the law of the excluded middle nobody
likes to read about fiction set a
hundred years in the future the science
fiction writers you'd rather be zipping
around the galaxy the people right in
realism want to read about right now and
it's just more science fiction so you
see what I'm saying it's the law of the
excluded middle
and if you go in that zone you well if
you hg wells you can pull it off or you
can try to me because it's a empty
ecological niche in the world of stories
it's actually there's some new stories
to tell there and you what you need is
an audience that doesn't care and be is
willing to try it and so you have to
construct that audience yourself and I
think I have to the extent that I have
and you know I am NOT a gigantic
bestseller relative to many of my my
contemporaries so then the other one the
positive and the negative utopias are
also hard it was the dispossessed that
was the first successful utopian novel
before that you had maybe Huxley's
Islands Robert Graves seven days in new
Crete and you had some interesting
attempts to make a story going right
back to HG Wells as a modern utopia but
mostly the stories are away what Damon
not used to call the walk through the
zoo they'd get you well here's our
sewage plan and oh here's the house of
parliament and that plot would be a way
to show you the Utopia and only at the
dispossessed I would claim is the first
great utopian novel there it's like
combining a soap opera with
architectural blueprints so how natural
does that say
so I've lost some sleep over that one
and I think it's hard alright we're uh
we're just about at our time I did get a
note from Laura welcher I believe ahead
of our Rosetta project our endangered
languages project very long now who
points out that Ishii was actually yahi
not your ah oh okay and that in fact
there are still some speakers of Yurok
so yeah but let's thank you Laura thank
you alright sorry your fact-checking
live on stage so so you're gonna stick
around you're gonna you're gonna sign
books and and please come up say hi
get your book signed yeah maybe one last
question about Ursula and the community
of science fiction writers and maybe
sort of thinking about you know you were
saying a couple things backstage about
you know science fiction is kind of a
village it's kind of a or a community I
don't know how you would characterize it
but it's it's I don't know if it's it it
was more a closer knit community and in
an earlier time there's a lot I've heard
Greg bear talk about kind of a con
culture and and all the the conventions
that would go on back in the day I'm not
sure if that's sort of still there but
is there and and Ursula well being this
the star and this female star who got
more maybe more recognized than you know
a lot of other female writers as both a
exemplar and as a great artist but also
where she kept connected to the
community I think that there's a new
documentary out about her and you see
right or after writer who says that she
you know made this this connection with
her she taught a lot of folks over the
years this is something you want to say
that kind of maybe end this about her
and the the community of writers whether
it's an exemplar
yeah I'm gonna think on my feet here
always hard and I'm gonna say that it's
9 section is like a small town that in
some science fictional accident like the
cyclotron and a Philip a dick novel that
got blasted across space it's all over
the earth it reconvenes it's science
fiction conventions on a regular basis
but meanwhile it's scattered everywhere
but it has the dynamics of a small town
the Solidarity the backbiting the all
the good all the bad of a soap opera in
the blueprint so it's a people talk
about ghetto culture it's from the
European ghettos that there's a intense
esoteric regard for each other and a
private language and the outside is seen
as an outside the mainstream we used to
call it and so you would some people
like it when the walls come down and
you're just one group among the rest
other people like it better if they're a
big fish in a little pond and would
prefer the walls to stay up so all that
all those dynamics are going on and I
think there's always a kind of a mayor
figure the one that is the the everybody
in the town trusts and then there's the
ambassador figure the one that's made it
big in the outside world but everybody
in the small town likes and is proud of
so Bradbury was like an ambassador
figure he came out of fandom and out of
the community and he became a mainstream
star in America and spoke for science
fiction to the and fantasy to the larger
culture and then the mayor's sometimes
you don't know who they are Gardner
Dozois was mayor science fiction for a
long time Connie Willis is mayor a
science fiction george RR martin is both
mayor and ambassador at the same time
and so Ursula was one of those
ambassador figures this is what I'm
thinking now is that everybody in the
community almost everybody except for
the occasional you know small town the
one she had some knives in her back from
people in the community that I think
were jealous or envious but mostly we
were intensely proud of her because she
spoke well for science fiction she did
not go out to the world and say well
the kind of implied tokenism well I did
come from science fiction but I'm so
much better than that that's why you're
paying attention to me and that's why
I'm a star in the big world and I could
name X Y & Z that do that in their
interviews I find it annoying at best
sometimes maddening I hate that kind of
[ __ ] and Ursula would never do that
and she wanted to be regarded as herself
and a figure in American literature but
she also wanted it to be understood that
she had come out of the science fiction
community so she's one of those
ambassadors I think there's real reason
to be proud of her and I think she did a
great job I mean every once in a while
on stage or in print she would smack
people for putting science fiction down
and it was often hilarious you can look
up online her somebody had said science
fiction has crawled back up out of the
grave of genre or some phrase and she
made an entire short story out of it a
Lovecraft short story where the science
fiction crawls up in grabs that that
writer by the throat in the middle of
the night it's actually kind of creepy
so she she did I think keep the balance
and do just what you would wanted to so
I think that she was beloved in fact you
can I can end with this the tributes
made to her after her death the many
many many written tributes it's already
a kind of a collection not quite of
personal memories which you'd want more
a lot of them are just literary tributes
from people who loved the work which is
also cool but there's something unusual
about that
there's many and many a writer that
could die who everybody considered to be
a very very fine writer who would not
get that response on their death that
she got so that's worth thinking about
why and I think it comes to the the
warmth of her work Thank You Stan yeah
[Applause]
[Music]